welcome back so today i'm going to derive
the reynolds average navier-stokes equations
for the momentum part of the navy or stokes
equations last time we saw how we could take our
turbulent velocity field u which is a function
of space and time and we can decompose it into a
mean flow field an average flow field
time averaged plus all of the turbulent
fluctuations that vary in time and when we take
this this reynolds decomposition and plug it into
the navier-stokes equations we can get simpler
expressions or simpler equations for the mean
uh velocity field components which might be what
we care about as engineers if i'm going to design
an aircraft or a wing i might just care about
the average drag or the average lift and i might
not want to or be able to afford to simulate
all of these turbulent fluctuations i might
want to average those out and just see how they
affect the mean kind of the bulk flow quantities
and last time we did this by taking the
the reynolds decomposition this kind of
mean plus fluctuations and we plugged it into
the mass continuity equation the divergence of u
equals zero equations this should be a vector u
and we found by pretty simple arguments that from
this equation the divergence of the mean flow had
to be zero and the divergence of the fluctuating
components had to be zero and
so we're going todo the same thing today but for the full momentumequation up here
which is a lot hairier, a lot morecomplicated.
So I'm kind of looking forward tothis. This is going to be one of the most involved mathematical derivations i've done on
this board i think we're going to fill up the
whole thing so i'm pretty excited to get started
this is you know going to be a workout this
is like going to the gym or eating your kale
it's going to make you stronger
and i know thatwe all love kale
So let's jump in.  And I'll alsopoint out I'm not actually going to derivethe entire vector momentum equation
because it would be way too big for this setup so
what i'm going to do is i'm actually going to show
you how this works for just the u or x momentum
the first component of this momentum equation
and we're going to plug this decomposition
into the first row of this vector equation
and so kind of in components the
equation i'm going to solve or write down
is u sub t this is little u, the
first component of the velocity field
plus and this convection term we can
essentially write this as u partial partial x
plus v partial partial y plus w partial partial zee
or zed depending on which side of the pond you're on
all of that applied to little u equals minus
partial partial x of p okay minus partial p
partial x plus 1 over the Reynolds number the
Laplacian of the first component of u, so del
squared of little u here so i'm just solving this
for the x component the first component of the
momentum equation of my Navier Stokes that's
just the first row of this vector equation
i've written down here and we are going to plug in
the Reynolds decomposition we're going to plug in
this expression here for all of the terms
expand it out and we're going to time average
and see what terms drop out we're going tosee if we can get a simplified expression just in terms of the mean flow
Great, okay. Solet's do it...
Can't stall when you're derivingthe RANS equations...
so for u sub t little u
is u bar the average u plus u prime so this
is and i'm going to give myself a little place
to work here so right here so i have u bar sub t
plus little u prime sub t and subscript here is
going to be a partial derivative with respect to t
okay good plus now every single one of these
terms this u partial partial x is really going
to be big u bar uh plus you know partial
partial sorry let me slow down this is u
partial u partial x plus v partial u
partial y plus w partial u partial z
and so for this u and this u i'm going to be
plugging in uh u bar plus u prime okay good and
i'm going to get a bunch of cross terms just like
when you multiply polynomials x plus y squared you
get the cross terms we're going to get a bunch of
cross terms here this is going to be the nastiest
part of the expression so let's try this out
and let's hope i can get this right so this is
u bar u bar sub x uh that's
just partial with respect to x
plus u bar little u prime sub x plus uh little
u prime u bar sub x plus little u prime little
u prime sub x that's what i get if i take
u bar plus u prime and i plug it into this
first term u bar plus u prime prime partial
partial x of u bar plus u prime and i do the
same thing for the second term and the third
term okay so now i'm going to have plus v bar
u bar now it's a derivative with respect to y plus
uh v bar little u prime sub y plus okay uh plus v
u bar u bar uh good plus little v prime u bar sub
y plus little v prime u prime sub y this is a this
is hard to keep all of this uh going so please you
know follow along and yell through the screen if
i get something wrong okay plus now we have to do
for the the w component and i'm hoping i can just
do this by pattern matching w bar u bar sub z
plus w bar little u prime sub z plus little w
prime my fluctuations in the w direction u bar z
plus little w prime little u prime sub z that's
just my convection term and now i have uh these
last two terms my pressure gradient and my viscous
diffusion so that's a little bit easier and i'm
going to say all of this stuff equals equals
and it equals um minus p bar x minus p
prime x plus 1 over my reynolds number
del squared of u bar plus 1 over my
reynolds number del squared of u prime
okay that is step one so step one is to take
my reynolds decomposition plug it into the x
component of my momentum equation and this is
all of the terms that i get but fortunately
a lot of these terms are going to die really
really quickly okay so they were not meant
for this world so this u bar is by definition
we've averaged time out this does not vary in time
so when i take its partial with respect to time
that's zero and now the next step is essentially
we're going to time average this entire equation
we're going to time average every single term
in this equation and we're going to use these
identities here to kill as many terms as possible
okay so uh and there's two equations that i'm
going to use extensively i'm going to use this one
and this one and i guess i'm also going to use
this one well i'm using all of them to be honest
uh i guess i'm using all of these so the time
average of this entire equation is the sum of
the time averages of every piece that's this term
anytime i see a loan u prime and i time average it
i can kill it even if it has a partial derivative
because the time average of a partial derivative
is the partial derivative of the time average
now you're going to have to take your time and
convince yourself of these last two just you know
get a big sheet of paper and try to work this out
and convince yourself that these two are true but
it allows me to kill this term when i time average
and when i time average my u bar u bar x nothing
changes because the time average of a time average
is just the same time average so this is unchanged
this is unchanged uh any term that has one average
component and one fluctuating component when
i time average it it is the product of the
time averages and the time average of u prime x
is zero so this term is zero this term is zero
all of the terms that have a single fluctuating
component are zero which is huge we just killed
like half of our terms uh my pressure prime
fluctuation is going to die out when i average
my laplacian of u prime is going to die out when
i average and these become average average average
so this is my time averaged reynolds averaged
navier stokes equation for the first component
of my of my momentum equation so right
off the bat i've eliminated most of the
terms i just have a few terms left and so
i'm going to group those kind of over here
and we're going to see if we can simplify even
more okay so let's do that and i want to make sure
to kind of get this right this is really
important so over here i'm going to write
that i have u bar u bar x i'm gonna first group
all of my average terms all of my mean flow terms
uh plus v bar u bar y plus w bar u bar z or z plus
all of my fluctuating components plus uh little u
prime little u prime x time average plus v prime
u prime y time average plus w prime u prime
z time average okay these are all of my turbulent
fluctuating components notice these didn't go away
this is actually troublesome i wanted an equation
just in terms of mean flow components but i have
these pesky turbulent fluctuations here and these
are not zero the average of products of primes are
not zero very important i should put that here
uh u prime squared average is not zero super
important okay again convince yourself that this
is true these are essentially the variances of
the turbulent fluctuations the average turbulent
fluctuation is zero the variances are absolutely
not zero they're they have variance that's the
definition of uh of turbulence pretty much okay
and then there are two more terms this equals uh
my pressure gradient minus p bar x plus 1 over the
reynolds number of the laplacian of u bar so this
is a much much simpler equation right off the bat
there is no time varying term this doesn't vary
in time these are all average to quantities so
if i knew what these uh turbulent fluctuations
were i could solve for my mean flow variables
and i could get my average drag or average lift on
my wing okay but these quantities here are a real
pain these are called reynolds stresses or they're
related to reynolds stresses because they kind of
have the units of a stress and i'll i'll get to
that in a minute but what we're going to do now is
we're going to try to simplify these three terms
and make them a little bit easier to work with
so this is kind of step two we killed a bunch
of terms and we grouped them now step three
is i get to simplify this using essentially a
chain rule identity so i'm going to do that now
it really makes my life a lot easier so please
bear with me okay so down here we're just going
to try to simplify those terms and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to say i have u prime u prime
x that's this term i'm going to have v
prime u prime y and w prime u prime z
of course time average all of them and i'm
going to set these each equal to something
where the second term is going to add up
to zero so i'll just show you so this is um
partial u prime partial uh u prime u prime partial
x all of that time averaged minus uh u prime
partial u prime partial x again all of that time
average sorry this is getting a little crowded
this is just the chain rule if you take this
term partial u prime squared partial x then
essentially it is 2 u prime partial u prime
partial x that's 2 u prime u prime partial x
so these are equal and if i move this over here i
get two of them and that's just the chain rule of
this guy same thing i can chain rule this one and
i get that that is the partial of v prime u prime
uh with respect to y time average minus uh i guess
this would be a u prime partial v prime partial y
time average again if i chain rule v prime times u
prime with respect to y i get v sub y u prime plus
u sub y v prime so if i add these up i get that
by the chain rule and then the last one similarly
sorry this is just uh i trust me it's going to
make our lives easier and it's going to make it
much clearer what this term is the last one
is just partial w prime u prime partial z
averaged minus i guess u
prime partial w prime partial
z averaged but here's where it gets kind of
interesting if i take these three terms here
the u prime partial u partial x u prime partial v
partial y u prime partial w partial z all of this
added up because we're adding these three
up all of this added up is u prime times
the divergence of vector u prime little component
u prime times the divergence of the vector u v
w and we know from the last lecture that
the divergence of the fluctuations is zero
so this whole term equals zero these three
terms add up to zero so the sum of these
is the sum as the same as the sum of these so
that's where it gets really nice is i'm going to
uh simplify this and i'm going to write down that
this uh these three terms here are just uh u prime
u prime average partial partial x plus u
prime v prime average partial partial y plus
partial partial z of u prime w prime
that's what these three terms become
and i still have my other terms i still have my u
bar u bar x plus v bar u bar y plus w bar u bar z
and all of this equals minus p bar x plus
one over reynolds number of laplacian
of u-bar this should be a big u whatever it
doesn't matter u-bar okay good so now we have
finally arrived at the kind of expression i
wanted which is we took the reynolds decomposition
we plugged it into the navier-stokes
equations the first component only
here and i time average to kill most of the terms
we collected the terms that stayed alive here
and we have these pesky terms that contain just
these fluctuating turbulent components we use
some math identities here to simplify we basically
use the divergence free part of the fluctuation
components to get this final expression this is
the reynolds average navy or stokes equations
at least the first component of it you could
do this for the second component for a little
v sub t the third component for little w sub t
and you would get three of these big equations
now here's the part i really wanted to get to
which is this equation is almost exclusively
in terms of mean variables averaged variables
the bulk properties of the flow that i want
to know about like my average drag and my
average lift are going to be computed from
but i have these pesky terms here these are
called the reynolds stresses these are my reynolds
stresses and they stress us all out in
turbulence modeling in fact it's literally the u
prime u prime bar that's a reynolds stress
u prime v prime bar is a reynolds stress
and u prime w prime bar is a reynolds stress
because when you take their gradient or their
partial derivatives with respect to space
you get a term that has the units of force
per volume just like these uh stresses so you can
kind of move these terms down here and they act to
force the the mean flow variables kind of how a
stress would and so the whole game of turbulence
modeling the whole uh strategy of reynolds average
navy or stokes and other turbulence modeling
is to try to approximate these quantities which
depend on the turbulence fluctuations i need
to know my u prime of space and time this is a
mess to compute can i approximate these reynold
stresses in terms of the mean flow and it's only
going to be an approximation it is not going to
be exact we're going to lose information but if i
can approximate these reynolds stresses in terms
of these mean flow quantities then i have a chance
of actually solving this for u bar v bar and w bar
which tells me a lot about the bulk properties of
my engineering flow okay so we're going to go way
more into depth kind of deriving some of these
closure models looking at what are some of the
models for these turbulent fluctuations of these
reynold stresses in terms of these big bulk mean
flow properties and then we're going to look at
how you can start using deep neural networks and
machine learning to get these closure models
from data so that's all coming up it worked